êtes-vous capable de me citer au moins
une grande ville qui est dans cette zone
juste ici bon évidemment si vous même
vous habitez ici c'est un peu de la
triche alors moi une ville ouais
[Musique]
ouais non ah si non
Toulouse quelque part là Montpellier
après c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
quand même peut-être Limoges ou c'est
question suivante
nombreuses sont les personnes à ne pas
savoir forcément ce qu'il y a dans cette
zone et pour cause on la surnomme
parfois la diagonale du vide bon c'est
pas totalement vide là-bas d'ailleurs le
terme est plus trop utilisé aujourd'hui
il y a simplement beaucoup moins
d'habitants qu'ailleurs on appelle ça
tout simplement un lieu à faible densité
et on considère que c'est le cas quand
il y a moins de 30 habitants au
kilomètre carré pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée la moyenne en France c'est
de 105 habitants par kilomètre carré
donc là on est beaucoup moins et
d'ailleurs il y a d'autres zones en
France qui sont très peuplées elle
s'affiche ici
et juste là et oui je sais effectivement
je pense que je peux tenter une
reconversion à devenir présentateur
météo dans les zones que vous voyez ici
on compte seulement
6,5% de la population française
métropolitaine pourtant et bien ces
espaces représentent 42% du territoire
national mais alors pourquoi la
diagonale du vide comme elle était
appelée pendant longtemps est aussi vide
encore aujourd'hui et bien c'est un
sujet passionnant et on va le voir
ensemble aujourd'hui
cette diagonale elle a commencé à se
dessiner entre 1850 et 1950 à l'époque
les gens qui habitent dans cette
diagonales travaillaient majoritairement
dans les champs sauf que des 1850 un
objet va apparaître il va bouleverser
leur quotidien il s'agit de la
moissonneuse voilà à l'époque vous vous
en doutez une moissonneuse ça
ressemblait plutôt à ça mais c'était à
l'époque une véritable révolution
c'est la disparition dans nos campagnes
du cheval à quatre jambes
au provinces de prendre le nom
d'industrie agricole en fait la
moissonneuse comme la faucheuse ou la
batteuse à l'époque vont réduire les
besoins de main d'oeuvre dans les champs
et concrètement au lieu d'avoir 100
personnes pour récolter à la main on en
a plus qu'une seule une personne donc
qui va conduire la machine du coup à
cette époque il y a moins de travail sur
place et dans les champs alors que à
l'inverse dans les villes c'est
absolument le contraire dans les villes
donc dans la seconde moitié du 19e
siècle les entreprises commencent à
produire massivement elles deviennent
plus grandes c'est la période donc de
l'industrialisation conséquence
certaines régions très rurales vont voir
leur population déménager directement
dans les villes c'est ce que l'on
appelle parfois à l'exode rural mais
toutes les régions ne sont pas égales
face à l'industrialisation la plupart
des régions agricoles ont vu une partie
de leur population partir mais d'autres
régions comme par exemple les hauts de
France on réussit à cette époque bon
d'ailleurs un bon moment à maintenir une
Industri milieu rural et donc à retenir
leur population sur place pour éviter
donc qu'elle parte directement dans les
grandes villes du reste de la France
mais la moissonneuse ne va pas être le
seul objet qui va dessiner les
territoires de cette diagonale il y aura
aussi attention ça peut surprendre le
vélo vous m'avez déjà pris mes
chaussures maintenant pour comprendre on
va inventer un personnage on va
l'appeler Jean par exemple Jean il vit
dans un petit village dans notre fameuse
diagonale du vide au début des années 20
et dans son village chaque jour et bien
les marchands se déplacent ils viennent
donc lui vendre ce dont il a besoin pour
vivre mais Jean et bien achètent un jour
un vélo et tout cela va transformer son
quotidien le vélo c'est le premier moyen
de transport qu'il possède il va
l'utiliser en fait pour faire des
allers-retours dans la ville d'à côté
une ville qui est un petit peu plus
grande que la sienne et ça va donc lui
permettre d'aller chercher lui-même ses
produits dans cette plus grande ville ce
que fait Jean dans son petit village
d'autres personnes vont le faire aussi
dans leur village autour et c'est ainsi
donc qu'au lieu de se déplacer bien
désormais les commerçants ont commencé à
s'installer dans cette ville et c'est ce
que l'on appelle donc la concentration
les commerçants plutôt que de faire le
chemin vers la TV village pour rester
dans cette ville et c'est donc les
différents habitants des villages qui
vont venir chaque nouveau mode de
transport va en fait changer la manière
dont on se déplace ça va accélérer les
déplacements et par ailleurs ça va de
fait souvent diminuer le nombre d'arrêts
et le fait de diminuer le nombre d'arrêt
ça va concentrer la population sur
certains points sur certaines villes un
peu plus tard le petit-fils ou la petite
fille de Jean va acquérir une voiture
attention il vit toujours dans notre
diagonale mais cette fois-ci au lieu
d'aller faire ses courses dans la ville
où allégeant et bien ce petit-fils ou
cette petite fille pourra aller dans une
ville un peu plus loin cette autre ville
un peu plus loin gagnera donc ainsi en
activité aux dépens de l'autre bon et là
vous commencez à comprendre l'un des
premiers points plus on avance dans
l'histoire plus les transports
permettent d'aller encore plus loin et
donc plus on s'éloigne des petits
villages pour aller dans les grandes
villes et le TGV pour cela c'est un très
bon exemple voici le dernier né de
l'industrie ferroviaire française le TGV
001 le Super Turbo train sur un trajet
Paris - Lyon au lieu de s'arrêter 20
fois comme le faisait le train autrefois
le TGV ne s'arrêtera qu'une seule fois
sont terminus donc directement à Lyon
conséquence directe vous l'aurez compris
les villes entre Lyon et Paris se
retrouvent moins desservis et perdront
progressivement en attractivité en
activité et donc infini en taille de
population et d'ailleurs si on regarde
cette carte des gares TGV on voit bien
que notre diagonale du vide est
absolument absente des radars même chose
d'ailleurs lorsque l'on regarde les
villes où se trouve les grands aéroports
en France je vous laisse observer les
transports et particulièrement les
transports en commun mais aussi les
infrastructures pour les transports sont
développés là où il y a des gens en fait
on essaye de desservir la population
donc évidemment on va d'abord aller là
où il y a plus de populations et
peut-être là où il y en a moins il y a
moins de transport il y a donc via tous
ces phénomènes là des villes qui
attirent et des villes et des villages
au contraire qui ont tendance à se vider
si vous habitez dans un village de 1500
habitants vous êtes sûrement obligé
d'aller dans la ville d'à côté pour
aller voir un médecin voir la ville
d'encore plus loin pour aller à
l'hôpital et le meilleur exemple pour ça
ce sont les maternités les maternités
sont emblématiques de ce point de vue là
sur les campagnes en gros on considère
que pour avoir une maternité qui tourne
il faut 1000 naissances pour des
questions de sécurité d'entraînement du
personnel de dispositif médicaux
sanitaires et de fait dans les campagnes
aujourd'hui si vous avez pas ces 1000
naissances on va pas ouvrir de maternité
voir on va enfermer moins il y a de
maternité moins les jeunes couples vont
s'installer donc moins on aura de jeunes
populations plus la population ne va pas
croître c'est donc un cercle vicieux
plus la population s'en va moins il y a
de transport qui s'y arrêtent
il y a de commerces de médecins
d'hôpitaux ou encore d'école moins les
gens ont envie de s'y installer et donc
moins il y a d'enfants qui naissent
c'est ainsi que la population diminue
mais aussi avec elle les services
publics alors que qu'une population
reste tout de même présente sur place
c'est évidemment un sujet éminemment
politique on a déjà eu l'occasion
d'ailleurs d'en parler à de nombreuses
reprises dans notre format des actus du
jour que ce soit sur Youtube ou alors en
podcast si on regarde cette carte de la
densité de la population entre 1876 et
2017 on voit bien apparaître notre
fameuse diagonale aujourd'hui on met
l'accent sur le vide mais le vide c'est
aussi la présence de plein ailleurs et
les contrastes augmentent aujourd'hui en
France dans les contrastes augmentent
parce que une partie des zones les moins
peuplées continuent de se dépeupler et
puis surtout les zones les plus peuplées
continuent de se peupler plus de vide
plus de plein plus de contraste allez si
vous le voulez bien reprenons notre cher
diagonale on a donc vu qu'elle a été
tracée notamment car beaucoup de la
population ici est partie vivre en ville
mais il faut savoir que certains
territoires ici ou là étaient de toute
façon très peuplés de base et l'une des
raisons c'est ça la forêt et oui par
exemple le territoire des Landes n'a
jamais été très peuplé ça a été
longtemps une zone humide et puis au
milieu du 19e siècle on a décidé de
planter de la forêt notamment pour
essayer d'implanter de la population
mais quand vous plantez de la forêt vous
n'avez pas besoin de beaucoup
d'agriculteurs non plus pour s'en
occuper et donc finalement c'est un
territoire qui a toujours été peu peuplé
et qui malgré sa transformation en forêt
à partir de 1857 reste peuplé mais ça ne
concerne pas que les forêts une grande
partie de la diagonale du vide tombe
vous le voyez peut-être en plein massif
central c'est le massif montagneux le
plus vaste de France il représente
environ 15% du territoire de France
métropolitaine alors oui je suis
d'accord il y a pas des montagnes aussi
hautes que dans les Pyrénées ou dans les
Alpes mais tout de même et bien ça reste
des massifs montagneux et ça n'aide pas
forcément vraiment cette région à se
développer c'est vrai que les zones de
moyenne montagne en France sont moins
peuplées souvent que le reste du
territoire souvent c'est des zones avec
des pentes donc moins pratique pour
l'agriculture avec des sols parfois plus
pauvres et par ailleurs c'est aussi des
zones où les transports peuvent être
plus compliqués ou il y a pas de
ressources alternatives de type
industriel pas de minerai etc donc ça
fait que les moyennes montagne sont
depuis longtemps moins dense et n'ont
pas profiter des développements du 19e
et du 20e siècle en moyenne ou en haute
montagne c'est aussi compliqué pour les
transports pour construire des routes il
faut construire des tunnels des viaducs
faire des chemins en lassés et tout ça
et bien ça peut coûter très très cher et
signe que niveau transport c'est
compliqué et puis qu'il y a donc ce
cercle vicieux que j'évoquais à
l'instant l'Ardèche par exemple et le
seul département de France
métropolitaine sans gare pour le public
il y a uniquement des trains de
marchandises mais impossible aujourd'hui
de prendre un train dans une gare
directement en Ardèche dans le Cantal
par exemple c'est un problème assez
aucun axe de circulation ne coupe le
département en deux la faute notamment
au volcan au milieu du département tous
les axes vont donc tourner autour et
forcément tous les trajets au quotidien
vont devenir assez longs et ça rejoint
donc ce que je vous disais à l'instant
ces territoires ils sont par exemple
utilisés pour l'élevage exemple avec la
forêt du Morvan ou autour on peut
trouver ces magnifiques bovins charolais
d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote dans certains
de ces départements on compte
littéralement plus de vaches que
d'habitants bon et si vous croyez
vraiment pas la preuve avec cette carte
qui a été réalisée par l'excellent
cartographe Jules Grandin bref là on
voit donc que ces territoires de la
diagonale soit ils étaient peuplés de
base pour des raisons géographiques soit
et bien ils se sont vidés
progressivement au fil de l'histoire
mais alors qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
maintenant et est-ce que ce territoire
sont en train de se repeupler et bien si
on jette un œil dans les médias voici
une petite compilation de tout ce que
l'on peut lire on entend de plus en plus
de témoignages de personnes qui quittent
la ville pour la campagne et encore plus
d'ailleurs depuis le covid ou encore le
télétravail exemple frappant Paris a
perdu plus de 120 000 habitants en 10
ans et compte aujourd'hui moins
d'habitants qu'en 2000 ces gens qui sont
vont ils ont un nom il s'appelle les
néoruraux et finalement c'est un petit
peu l'inverse de l'exode rural les
néo-ruraux interne apparus
au milieu et qui englobe toute cette
frange de la population qui en a marre
de la ville parce que oui vivre à la
campagne c'est un mode de vie donc
beaucoup d'Urbain rêve un petit peu
secrètement en tout cas sur le papier
bon il y a plein de raisons qui peuvent
expliquer cette envie en tout cas de
partir des villes la pollution le bruit
la surpopulation les prix etc etc je
pense que vous êtes nombreux à connaître
du coup logiquement et bien si les
villes se vident et que les gens soient
disant partent à la campagne notre cher
diagonale devrait a priori se repeupler
sauf que c'est faux vous l'aurez compris
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on observe la
réalité est tout autre la plupart des
gens déménagent de villaville et
pourquoi on en entend beaucoup parler je
pense que d'abord ça fait rêver et puis
finalement c'est le phénomène un peu
exceptionnel quand vos amis déménagent
en ville donc il déménagent quand
quelqu'un part de la ville pour aller à
la campagne c'est un événement
exceptionnel donc on a tendance à se
focaliser dessus en fait quand on
regarde un peu plus dans le détail cette
diagonale elle ne gagne pas en
population mais alors où vont les gens
qui petite les grandes villes et bien
ils vont finalement juste à côté en
général c'est ce que l'on appelle
l'étalement urbain c'est le
développement de peuplement donc
l'installation de population autour des
villes et donc c'est finalement
l'extension de la ville dans l'espace
selon l'Insee les communes peu peuplées
situées à côté des grandes villes sont
celles qui connaissent la plus forte
croissance de la population par exemple
à Issy-les-Moulineaux dans les
Hauts-de-Seine une ville vraiment collée
à Paris c'est bien que certains
considèrent que c'est une forme de
prolongement de Paris le nombre
d'habitants a augmenté de 31% entre 1999
et 2015 et on observe la même chose dans
toutes les grandes villes de France on
va penser à Villeurbanne situé à côté de
Lyon avec ses 20% d'augmentation de la
population entre 1999 et 2015 ou encore
à Martigues à côté de Marseille avec une
augmentation de 13%. sachant que pour
des villes comme celle-ci ça peut être à
la fois les personnes qui n'étaient pas
dans la région et qui viennent
s'installer directement dans cette ville
ou alors certaines personnes qui étaient
au cœur de la ville et qui pour avoir un
peu plus de place décide donc d'aller en
banlieue bon mais vous l'aurez compris
quand on parle de Martigues
d'Issy-les-Moulineaux ou alors de
Villeurbanne ce n'était pas des zones à
faible densité de base et à l'inverse
dans la Creuse par exemple et bien on a
moins d'habitants aujourd'hui qu'il y a
un siècle il y a pas de peuplement
actuellement dans les zones à faible
densité les Français continuent de
déménager et il y a pas eu de gros
changements après le covid et les
déménagements c'est d'abord de vie la
ville de métropole à métropole
éventuellement dans le dans le
périurbain donc autour des villes et
dans les campagnes littorales cela dit
c'est annucé il y a effectivement des
gens qui partent vivre à la campagne
dans des zones à faible densité sauf que
ces gens se sont eux
et oui des retraités alors c'est déjà
pas mal ça permet d'avoir de nouveaux
clients pour les commerces une nouvelle
dynamique éventuellement dans ces
villages ou alors ces petites villes
mais à moins que ce soit Robert De Niro
ou Al Pacino et bien ces personnes ne
feront plus en France et donc n'aideront
pas repeupler cet endroit par ailleurs
des retraités sont plutôt sur la fin de
leur vie donc les installations de
retraité ça va être 20 30 ans et de fait
ça suffit pas à relancer des dynamiques
démographiques alors attention il y a
quelques territoires quand même qui se
sont repeuplés c'est le cas par exemple
des campagnes ou des petites villes qui
peuvent être près des littoraux c'est le
cas en Bretagne c'est le cas on vendait
mais aussi tout autour de la
Méditerranée c'est devenu donc des
destinations qui plaisent beaucoup des
destinations évidemment très
touristiques mais là aussi ça reste
assez variable selon les régions et
d'ailleurs très bon exemple pour
comprendre tout ça on va prendre
l'exemple du Var sur cette carte on voit
que le département est véritablement
coupé en deux par l'autoroute en bas la
population est très dense mais en il y a
très très peu d'habitants qui sont
présents bref aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
parler de repeuplement il suffit de voir
cette carte de l'Insee datant de 2019 on
voit que cette fameuse diagonale est
encore là alors cette diagonale est-elle
condamnée à être si peu peuplé par
rapport au reste de la France très dur
de prévoir l'avenir mais on peut
imaginer quelques scénarios qui
pourraient pousser éventuellement les
personnes à retourner dans ses campagnes
isolées d'ici 20 à 30 ans la première
chose qui pourrait aider c'est les
questions liées à l'innovation en gros
on peut imaginer que si des éléments
comme par exemple la fibre optique et
déployée partout et bien ça pourrait
devenir un peu plus attractif pour des
personnes par exemple qui travaillent
beaucoup en télétravail bon après comme
on l'a dit à l'instant ça reste un
nuancer ils peuvent aussi décider de
s'installer simplement à l'extérieur des
grosses villes le deuxième scénario
c'est celui du changement climatique
vous le savez il va faire de plus en
plus chaud chaque année en 2050 les
températures pourraient parfois
atteindre des 50 degrés en ressenti dans
les grandes villes voici la carte donc
prévue avec vous le voyez des
températures égales ou supérieures à 40
degrés on pourrait donc imaginer une
fuite de la population vers la campagne
où l'air est plus respirable et moins
polluée bon mais là encore ce qui est le
plus probable c'est que ce soit les plus
riches qui partent et ce sera uniquement
en période estivale dans une résidence
secondaire par exemple il ne vivront
donc pas forcément toute l'année sur le
territoire et ça ne participera pas
forcément donc au repeuplement il y a la
dynamisation de ces régions troisième
scénario le plus catastrophe qu'on
pourrait citer qui pourrait t'entraîner
un repeuplement de ces régions c'est
celui d'une théorie de l'effondrement
théorisé notamment par le chercheur
Jared Diamond c'est l'idée donc que la
société pourrait être frappée par
plusieurs crises tellement forte que les
banques les supermarchés les grandes
entreprises ou encore les centrales
électriques feraient tous faillite une
crise sanitaire aussi serait possible la
population devrait donc se débrouiller
soi-même et une excellente série sur
Canal+ qui s'appelle effondrement à bord
de cette thématique on voit les
personnages tentés de fuir les villes
pour s'installer notamment en campagne
pour se nourrir c'est un scénario le
plus pessimiste mais qu'il faut quand
même noter bon et dernier scénario qui
lui en l'occurrence est une question de
volonté de la part des autorités ou
alors de l'État ce serait tout
simplement une question d'investissement
de la part des gouvernements successifs
pour s'assurer que déjà les populations
présentes dans ces territoires et des
services publics adaptés et faire en
sorte donc d'avoir une politique
d'investissement notamment en matière de
transport et d'hôpitaux pourront donc
ces petites villes ou ces villages à
nouveau attractifs
bref vaste sujet j'aurais pu en parler
pendant des heures il y a évidemment
beaucoup à dire encore sur le quotidien
des personnes et notamment des jeunes
qui peuvent habiter dans certaines de
ces régions merci beaucoup à Benjamin
accompagné de Lorie qui sont
journalistes au sein de l'équipe et qui
ont travaillé donc sur ce sujet prenez
soin de vous prenez soin de nos proches
et on se dit à très vite